Hey,
what's going on is bill burn.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
January 1st,
2018 oh my God.
It's a new year.
A new with the new year comes hopes in
jeans for a better world and God wants us
to sit there and try to make
it a better world. Well,
you should probably start with yourself.
Friends
have seen those people late night trying
to tell you how to make it a better
world,
you know,
or somebody writes a song about it,
make it a better place for you and for
me and the plumber down the street,
right?
Yeah.
It's very difficult. The older you get
to listen to those songs going like,
all right,
so,
okay.
Not only are you not going to
make the world a better place,
you're going to write some cheese ball
fucking song and make money off the fact
that people want to
make it a better place.
You're going to give some fucking
stupid pop culture psychology,
right? Pop Psychology. Is that
what you're going to throw out?
I don't know what the fuck it is.
It's like after nine 11 when that
country guy wrote that song, you know,
Uncle Sam's Buda, Buda, Buda, and you're
right. It's like, how did he like,
like that wasn't going to be a giant hit.
Yeah.
You know,
I dunno what I'm talking about.
All I could tell you is I'm doing this
Monday morning podcast on Tuesday, uh,
because I was like, well,
what do I do? Do I do it?
Do I do it the night before
I go to the Rose Bowl?
And then by the time I tell you the
Rosebowl stories, it's like four days old,
or do I just go to the rose
bowl and do it a little late?
I decided on the ladder.
All right.
And I apologize to any, I
dunno, whatever fucking group,
you know what I'm hoping
in 20 2018 happens,
I just hope that people start
standing up to all of this fucking,
you know,
the amount of people being offended,
it's not that you get offended,
it's the level of coverage that it gets
compared to shit that really is way,
way, way more devastating
to realize. By the way,
you know what's really was bugging me,
you know,
and there was all those
hurricanes and everybody,
everybody sending fucking money
out and all alleged shit, right?
You gotta help all these people in
Houston guy to help all these people in
Florida. Hey, where
the fuck were you guys?
Wouldn't the Hollywood hills were on fire?
Ha, I didn't see any fucking benefits
for fucking, what's his name? Ralph
Nader. What's the fucking guys name?
Who Owns Fox?
Whatever the fuck his name is.
Will that poor bastards
mansion was catching on fire?
Did any of you fucking people floating on
a mattress, a Houston a few months ago?
Rub a couple of nickels
together and send it to him.
Make some teary eyed videos.
I just kind of seems like
it's a one way street here.
The fuck is the guy's name alone is Fox.
Is it Ralph? It's one of those fucking
names where you see like, you know,
you know,
chicks didn't take him seriously in high
school and then all of a sudden he owns
like the biggest network ever.
And all those women there,
I should've fucked Ralph.
Why did I have to fuck to the quarterback?
Baker, mid fucking man's field,
whatever the fuck his name is.
The guy won the Heisman,
the hell's his name.
Baker Mayfield. Boom, boom, boom, boom.
[inaudible] sorry.
That was my bad.
Curtis may feel when I pull
a pass to that guy was, huh?
If I could sing and all these great songs,
he's doing a Goddamn cake and
the literally the lighting
falls down on them and
breaks his fucking neck. I mean, how,
how did he continue to write music?
I don't know how the fuck is at some
people. I don't know. I hate to say this.
I know this about myself at that
ever fucking happened to me.
I would just be yelling, kill me to
everybody who came walking into the room.
We're going to start your
rehab. Kill me, kill me.
Give me a fucking something.
I'm not strong enough to get through this.
Jesus. This is dark. Sorry. Whatever.
That's what happens when you just
fucking start running. You Yap.
All of a sudden this happens.
Okay.
So I'd like to apologize to all Curtis
Mayfield fence and anybody who stubbed
their toe.
Speaking of which I'm at the fucking
I co I cooked up a goddamn store this
weekend. I went out strong. All right.
So the great j law had Rosebowl tailgate
legend Jason Law had he fucking,
uh, he goes to put together the
menu, right? And he does, doesn't go,
we're doing burgers, we're doing dogs.
He just, he doesn't do that horse shit.
J fucking analyze like bill Belicheck.
He fucking looks okay.
Oklahoma is playing George's planes. The
next thing you know, he's like, well,
in Oklahoma, you know, they do
this tri tip something or other.
So he gets that going. I'd tell him, Hey,
you want me make a pie this year? Goes,
yeah, why don't you make
a Peach Pie for Georgia?
And He ties this whole fucking Oklahoma
Georgia thing together was incredible.
So I'd never made a peach pie. Right.
And I know peaches or out of season.
So I'm like,
why am I going to go down there and buy
some fucking out of season piece to some
poor fucking had to pick off of what
used to be his own property down in Costa
Rica, whatever the fuck they do.
However they do the the fruit nowadays.
Yeah,
I fucking, I say, I said, fuck it man.
I'll go down getting them canned peaches.
I'm going to get some goddamn canned
peaches. So I got some canned peaches.
Okay.
Pick the fucking recipe off the Internet.
And this is what I found with
recipes on the Internet. Okay?
They're going to get it to
you so it tastes really good,
but they're not going to,
they're not going to give you
the recipe or it tastes great.
So what they're gonna do is they're
going to, you don't remember that guy.
I'm going to bring it up a notch. Bam.
And he'd be screaming and yelling.
He had that fucking band,
Emeril lagasse right about how
he used to take it up a notch.
Do what they do on the Internet
is every fucking recipe.
They take it down a notch,
take it down a notch,
and then they fucking remove something.
They take something out,
some little specials, special spice.
So anytime you make an a fucking pie,
here's it's a little sage advice for you.
All right? It's going to be the usual.
Okay?
If you're doing some sort of fruit there,
it's going to be basically
a quarter cup of sugar.
I mean quarter cup of flour
and like a cup of sugar.
And then there's going to be cinnamon,
Nutmeg, uh, possibly vanilla,
I dunno, some sort of bullshit
and they're going to see 80 teeth,
Mooney the and like a teaspoon of that.
Fuck that fucked up.
Okay.
All right. They say eighth
of a teaspoon taken. Nice.
Helping of it with the eighth of a
teaspoon. That's what I do at Bam.
Throw that shit. Now what
do you want? A teaspoon?
I'll give you a teaspoon and a quarter.
Maybe a teaspoon and a half
if I'm feeling crazy. Right.
You just kind of bring the levels
up on everything and then you think,
what else would they have on their,
you know, they probably, you know,
squeeze a little lime on the peaches,
you know,
before they fucking do all of this shit,
right?
Maybe a little vanilla in there. And then
you always got to throw like, you know,
a little bit of butter in there
to mix all of that shit together.
Then you taste it. You throw a little more
sugar on top, you bring everything up.
That's what I did.
And uh,
I gotta tell you my gut rave reviews
on a peach pie. Who Knew, who knew?
You know, people, you know, if you don't
try to explore the limits of your talents,
you'll never truly find out
how great your life could be.
So I made a peach pie.
I made a practice one with Nia and it
was a deal I didn't have a lot of times.
So I actually went to the
store and bought a store,
bought frozen pie on the bottom,
sec religious,
and then I made a homemade one for on top,
you know,
cut my work in half.
And then there was this all this weirdness
where the one on the bottom was kind
of done, but the one on top
was, so I took it out and, uh,
you Nia took one bite of it and just
goes [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
does that shit. And I knew she was
right, but I also got mad at her,
you know what I mean? Cause I'm
lazy. I didn't want to go back,
so I fucking egg wash the Goddamn
pie because I forgot to do that.
Sprinkled some sugar on it,
threw it back in.
Then it was better than
I made a decent pie.
But then I brought all the levels up
and the one that I did to the rose bowl
fucking crushed,
or maybe people would just be nice.
I don't know. Um, I also
made a quiche Lorraine.
I've always wanted to make a quiche.
I mean, who doesn't like eggs?
Who does it like Pie Emmy right there.
You've got both things going on.
This is breakfast and dessert
all at the same fucking time.
And uh,
I go to make this thing and of course
knee is all over me looking at this,
looking at that, look at it. This,
I fucking stick to Kesha in there.
All right.
Do the whole damn thing.
I fucking 45 minutes in. You know, I'd
give it a little poke with the tongs.
It still looks jelly as hell.
So I leave it in for another 10 minutes
and then it looks pretty much solid and
I'm getting nervous dot. I'm going
to burn it. So I take it out,
I let it cool off a couple of hours later,
I cut into it. It looks a little runny,
but I'm too hungry so I don't give a shit.
So I'm eating it.
It's clearly needs to go back
into the oven for 10 minutes,
but it's fucking delicious.
So I get to try this. I think
it needs to be, you know,
I think it needs to go back to
the oven maybe for 10 minutes.
And she just cuts in and she goes,
Ooh.
And then eats and goes
[inaudible] [inaudible] and
I just went, you know what?
Fuck you. And she's like, well, I'm just
being honest. I'm like, I know. Yeah,
I know. I just want it, but it still
tastes good, right? She goes, yeah,
but it's running. His shit needs to
go back in the oven. I'm like, well,
he could have said it tasted good first.
And she stormed out of the room and then
I was like, I'll come on honey, come on.
I'm sorry.
Sorry,
I won't be like this in 2018
so I put it back in the oven for like
another 10 minutes. Actually, Nia did,
she finished the thing off and it,
it tasted fucking delicious.
And then before the fucking rose bowl,
um,
the night before, I'm thinking, all right,
[inaudible] is going to be making his
classic fucking a breakfast sandwich,
which is basically a English muffin.
He puts a little Havara,
ate cheese on one side and
then he has his avocado spread.
He does on the other side.
Then he cooks this fucking egg to absolute
perfection where it's not too runny.
It's not over hard. It's just
perfect. Not Quite over meeting, uh,
medium. It sounded like a medium
rare. So when you bite into it,
the egg yolk oozes out,
but it doesn't fall out of the
sandwich and all of that shit. Right.
And then also he,
he had marinated this,
this tri tip that he put on top of
that and it was the best fucking eggs.
It was such a good egg sandwich.
I only had one cause he goes,
you want to have another one? It's
like, no, I don't want to kill it.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
And the night before I had made
these hash browns, you know,
the thing about it is, is you don't
want to make the fucking things,
but you also don't want the
things to turn all brown and Shit.
So I actually did the whole mix and
then put it in a fucking Ziploc bag in
squished all the air out of it.
I possibly could stuck it in
the fridge and it was fine.
I cooked those fuckers up on the side.
At that point I was a little shit face.
I think I overdid it.
That's right.
I was already drunk before
breakfast even came out.
All right.
We had already loaded up the truck.
We put the game changer in there.
The game changer. Who by the way?
All right. The game changer is a,
is a flat top griddle with four burners.
All right.
In the propane gas,
I'm telling you right.
That's what the fuck you want to
bring to a cookout. That thing,
it's just, you never have to worry about
your fire going out. There's not like,
there's not all of this pressure.
There's none of that shit.
You just turn that fucking thing on.
Jay's just like a short order cook.
I've never had the last two years I've
never seen him so relaxed at a cookout
because before you know,
we had a Hibachi that's way down here.
We had another one that was up
on its legs. This guy is going,
he's doing like fucking 400 squats
an hour trying to cook everything,
making sure as fire doesn't
go out time and shit. And um,
and he cooks the whole time.
It's like he's cooking one thing.
He cooks a breakfast and he
cooked something in the middle,
then he cooks the dinner. So he was
always having to add shit and calls.
And all that means is over the
course of like six hours. Um,
yeah.
So the flat top grill that j
law had dubbed the game changer.
Um, he was just crushing
it all day. And um,
I had gotten these things
cause this was our 10th, um,
Rosebowl in a row.
And anybody who's married knows that
your 10 year thing is 10 and not only do
they know that the, you know,
10 the 10 anniversary, you,
there's no way you can go out and buy
something made out of tin for your wife
only and she's going to be happy with
that unless you met an absolute sweetheart
who doesn't mind being broke or it
doesn't mind that she married a cheek.
Fuck one of the other.
Anyways,
so I went out and I got these flasks
made up for me and Bartner cause we,
we were the original guys
who was just the two,
just the two of us the first year.
So I got a giant Roman numeral 10,
like the Superbowl engraved on the front
and on the back I just had Joe Barton,
Nick Rosebowl tailgate legend.
And then I did like the American Express,
the members sense and had oh nine and um,
next year law had gets his in a two years.
Feminists gets his,
although I have to correct you cause I
already had a made up and I thought that
they both came in 2010. Um, anyways,
so I'm out there throwing
the football around.
I've got some booze in me,
right?
I smoked a little weed, which I never do,
but I'm just trying to lay off the bows.
And uh, this is why I don't
smoke weed is because you know,
with booze, if you reach for a
bottle of vodka, you know, okay.
You know basically what the
punch to the face is going to be.
Or if you grab a beer, you know what
that's going to be. You grabbed some wine,
you know what that's going
to be when someone goes, hey,
you want to take a hit of this choice?
You don't know what the fuck it is.
Is that the, is it that shit that just
kind of makes you feel like, hey man,
like everything's gonna be alright man.
Or is it going to have you just
fucking staring at a Goddamn tree?
Hmm.
So I, you know, I dunno what,
what are you supposed to do?
Just take one hit and then stand there
and wait for your face to start melting
and be like, oh, well it didn't. This
is why I'm done with fucking weed too.
So I take a fucking hit. I
don't feel anything. I'm like,
oh, this must be the, the,
the light one.
So then I go back and in about two,
three times and exceed, you know, I'm
telling everybody at the Tailgate, I go,
hey man, listen. I know I'm really high
right now, but look at that fucking tree.
Isn't that fuck it.
That tree is fucking a mess.
Like some shit out of a horror movie.
Look at that.
Look at the way it's like bent like that,
and they're just laughing at me and I am
so at peace that I don't care that I'm
actually La. I don't give a fuck that
they're laughing at me. I'm just happy.
That point that I'm bringing them joy
is I make a complete fool of myself.
Um,
and I'm drinking from the flask
and then Jay throws a burger on.
We've got this grass fed fucking
grass fed fucking meet dude.
I fucking, it might've been
the best burger I ever had,
but also I was so high, I was just
talking to people about this fucking tree,
which felt like an intense
minute. So, you know, it was like,
at least probably what,
like 11 minutes. Um,
I ate at Burger, it was
fucking amazing. And, uh,
then I went over to a chair. I sat down
and I passed out for like two hours.
It,
Jay was making these fucking
meatball subs on a Brioche Bun.
And I completely, I the last
like four or five years in a row,
I have missed the main course.
And by the way,
Americans call it an inmate, call it a
main course, don't call it the entree.
Alright?
In French entree means to enter it.
That's actually the beginning of the meal
in somewhere across the fucking ocean
in the scurvy and the fucking
slavery and the indentured servitude.
However, whatever distracted
us, we fucked that up.
Entree means to enter.
That's the beginning. Okay.
So just say the main course and for
the main core cell had this, uh,
what do you have for entrees?
Um,
so I missed that. I woke up and, uh,
I ended up, I tried the pie with
the Alamo. It was fucking delicious.
Everybody loved it.
And at that point I was kind of fucking
sober because I was actually way more
high than I was shit faced. And, um,
I didn't even smoke a
cigar and I went into the,
I went into the game
and, uh, I just started,
anytime a vendor came by
just started crushing waters,
I was already on the wagon. That's how
fucked up I got at the tailgate. Like,
you know,
like when you're still legally drunk and
you're already back on the what you're
telling people,
I'm on the wagon as you have
like literally they could
let your breath on fire.
Um, that's, that's what,
you know, you went to hard.
I don't really have any fucking stories
about the tailgate cause I barely
remember it. Um, other than
it was fucking awesome.
I do remember I was drinking, uh, uh,
millers. I was drinking out of
that flask. I had, you know,
once a year a mill.
I had Miller and Miller lite.
Miller lite comes back with their old
school, less filling tastes. Great bottle.
So I add a couple of those.
Um,
I threw the football around lefty.
I vaguely remember that. Oh.
And then somebody at the tailgate told
me a fucking story about how Garappolo
ended up on the fucking 40 niners.
Evidently the Cleveland browns
were interested in getting him,
but bill Belicheck still holds a grudge
against them for him, for his time,
you know, 1995 when he was coaching at
which I believe he was also with fucking,
what's his face?
Nick Saban there.
So he's like, fuck that. And
he calls up to 49 is, he goes,
give me a second round draft pick.
We'll give you a grappler.
How fucking nuts as a, I've wrote
a couple of those stories recently.
Like, do you know the Celtics got into
a position to g to get Bill Russell?
This is a story that was told to me.
Sit down,
gather around and listen to this tale.
Um,
the Celtics had too good of a year to
be in a position to draft Bill Russell.
So radar back makes a bunch of fucking
moves to get all the way up to number two.
Alright. But the problem is
is the Rochester royals is
some shit head number one.
There was nothing he could do
to get them to not, you know,
to give up the number one pick and
everybody was going to take Bill Russell.
He was just clearly the best guy.
So the Boston got it,
had the fucking ice capades every year
and they used to make a bunch of money
off that.
Now you,
I know a lot of you fucking millennials
out there like the ice capades bunch of
people twirling around,
dress on the ice, right?
Skating around dress like
fucking Yogi and booboo bear.
Why the fuck would I go see that bullshit?
Well, it was before the Internet,
the one you had a little black and
white fucking TV, you know what I mean?
The picture was always jumping.
This was just some exciting shit.
There wasn't a teddy bar or fucking free
internet porn. Every once in awhile,
you know, once a year, these beautiful
fucking goddess women would come in,
what their shapely thighs and he could
sit there and look at them and pretend
you were into the yard and just sat right
next to your wife. You could fuck it.
You know, look at some
games over there, right?
So would,
it would always sell out.
So the Rochester royals
were hurting for money.
So red our back called up the
ice capade guy. He goes, Hey,
can you do me a fucking solid?
Can you fucking get the ice capades can
you guarantee that you'll do a couple of
dates out there for these fucking
guys? He said, absolutely I will.
So he called them up as it, listen, I'll
get you to give me the number one pick.
I gave you the fucking
ice capades for a week.
You make all this goddamn money in
the miser that owned the team said,
you know what, I'll take
that deal. I will say,
forget Bill Russell.
So Dorothy Hamill can
come in or Peggy Fleming,
whoever the fuck it was back there.
I Dunno way back then.
It was probably some woman named Ethel
and she was considered hot, right?
Bethel McGuire in Hazel said,
Gorski or come and skate. Oh my God,
she's so fucking hot. Right. Years
later they wrote on the golden girls,
but back then they were
a hot piece of ass.
Now I know I skipped over
a lot of fucking details,
so you should probably listen to
the Bill Simmons podcast, right?
To figure out what really happened.
But that's what was told to me.
And you know what,
God damn and I'm sticking with it.
I'm fucking sticking with that story.
So anyways, all Billie, no fun.
I'm not going a bunch of days
again, but like, I'm just like, uh,
I'm done.
All right.
I came off the wagon on December 26th
and now it's January 2nd and I'm right
back on. I had, I had a hell of a week.
One day I didn't drink. All
right. That was the 28th.
December 20th. So six out of
the last seven days I drank. Uh,
I don't like how I feel.
I don't like how I look.
I just can't fucking do it anymore.
Okay. I'm turning 50 in June.
I had a great half of a century run.
All right.
I never really drank until I was like 17.
So what am I had a good 30 year
Larry Bird. Speaking of the guard,
I had a nice 33 year run.
Okay.
So, uh, I am now going to be
that guy that picks a spot.
Am I going to be that fucking dude?
Maybe I'd just be that guy that has a
glass of wine with dinner every once in
awhile.
You know,
it's just like,
just all this awkward silence between me
and my wife as we sit on either end of
this really long dinner table,
you know,
and all you hear is just me like turning
the pages of the paper and you know,
shaking it, you know, you can do that
thing to make sure it straightens out
every once in a while
just being like, oh, new.
Did you see down in Brazil in a really?
Um, I don't know what
I'm going to do, but uh,
I'm, I'm just, I'm,
I'm bringing the way I was bringing
everything up in that recipe.
I'm bringing everything down,
bringing everything down.
All right.
I'm fucking, uh, back to crushing
the waters on back on my diet.
And I got a couple of goals this year.
All right.
On the biggest mistakes I made in my
adult life was buying 34 inch jeans after
being a 32. All right, 32
best shape of my fucking life.
They started getting a little tight around
the fucking waste and I thought, oh,
you know, you get older, you fill out,
and it's like, no bill, you put on weight,
you can't, why don't you just take
fucking seven to 10 days to lose?
I didn't, I bought the
next size up jeans. Okay.
And that was stupid because that just
gave me this leeway to be a fat fuck.
Who feels comfortable in his pants?
You never buy the next size up jeans after
you're done growing and all that shit,
you know what I mean? Unless you're a
fucking bean pole, which may be, I was,
so I'm back down to 33.
I figure I'll stay there.
So that's what I'm going to do. I got
my fucking wardrobe right now. I got it.
It's just like, you know,
I hate going shopping.
All right.
And I have not bought a fucking
shirt or a pair of pants
in a couple of years.
Kind of fucking couple of free tee shirts.
I bought a Primus tee shirt at the
concert I went to. But other than that,
it is just, I just, you know,
and I got rid of a bunch of old clothes.
So I have like,
I have two shirts that I wear,
one of two shirts when I fucking had life.
Those are my two headlining shirts and
I think I have a pullover sweater and
that's it.
And uh,
I don't think I give a shit.
You know,
I got to go out there,
have some
fucking rhinestone shiny goddamn shirt.
I really believe that as long as I have
a fucking act that nobody's going to
read really paying attention to the shirt.
Right. Well now that I brought it up,
you're gonna.
MMM.
I Dunno. Maybe I'll buy Shannon, maybe
I'll buy a fucking sweat. You know,
I'm thinking, I'm thinking would be
that guy that just dresses all in black.
If I wasn't so fucking pasty
and I wouldn't look like
a floating head in hands,
I would do that.
But what's great about a black shirt,
you can wear that like three days in a
row before anybody really even notices
like this motherfucker's not
changing his shirt. You know,
that is the genius of
Malcolm young rest his soul,
the greatest rhythm guitarist and
rock and roll history, in my opinion.
MMM.
The genius of the way
that that meant dressed.
The sheer amount of money that that
man saved by just wearing jeans and a
fucking tee shirt,
right?
Einstein that said Einstein Shit.
That's what genius is.
Do they get rid of all the white noise
and they just focus on what's fucking
important.
I was what he did.
He just was just a Allie
needs pants and a shirt.
I'm not going to be fucking sitting
there trying to be in style.
I'm going to dress timeless blue jeans
and a fucking black tee shirt and I'm
done. Do you ever see the
left? There'd be rocked video.
That's one of my favorite parts of the
video when he's getting ready for the
show and he takes the t shirt off
and then he snaps his fingers,
like he says spoiled Rockstar and
they just throw him another tee shirt,
the exact same color he puts it on or a
slightly different color and then that's
it.
It's over.
MMM.
Anyways, my shoulder's been
doing great and then I fucked
it up at the, at the, uh,
the tailgate. By the way, I was throwing
lefthanded doing our right, you know,
making sure I was given my right
shoulder arrest and everything.
I hadn't felt any pain in my
shoulder for days. Long story short,
at the end of the end of the,
uh, the tailgate, we're going to
close up the table and uh,
I'm on one side of the other guys on
the other side and we're folding up the
legs and the one was getting
stubborn and where I had my fingers,
it fucking slammed down on
both of my fingers, right?
Just wham. And I went, ah,
fuck. And I pulled my arms out.
I was basically reaching around
the fucking table, you know,
like I was given the skinniest person
ever the finish who at that finishing move
in wrestling where they just put you in
a fucking bear hug and they would act
like he was being crushed to death.
I was doing that with the tables.
So when I went to Yank my arms
I really quickly, it was like,
it was like I was throwing two elbows
at the same time and I felt like fucking
lightning in my right shoulder.
And uh,
I think I went right back to square one.
I don't know what the fuck I got.
Do I think I'm going to do that Coby shit.
Um,
Robin told me about that whole stem
cells shit and I just get scared of that
stuff.
I Dunno the way Joe Rogan is fearless
and we'll read up on something and then
make an informed decision before
he takes a step in that direction.
I just hear about something new,
do not read up on it and act like an
old lady who thinks the fucking sky's
falling. That's the way I approach
life. So I haven't done that yet.
My shoulders still fucked up.
Um,
I might do that thing
where they take your own.
What I like about that fucking spinning a,
your blood is it your own blood and
then they shoot it back in. Right.
Although I would want to watch
them the whole time, you know,
follow them around with my own blood
to make sure they don't take like the
fucking blood of a yak or a fucking
chimp or some shit, whatever they,
whatever the fuck did with whatever
they're doing these days. Um,
to try to get that thing fixed.
Um, all right, let me, uh,
let me read to what do
I have any advertising?
Um, I don't know that I do during
the holidays. It's slows down.
I don't have any advertising.
Yeah.
Well what do you know?
What do Ya know? All right, let me see
here. I guess I don't have any advertise.
Well fuck it. Let's
continue talking. Alright,
this is what else I did on my wonderful,
over my wonderful holiday break.
I went down to the comedy store,
did it set, had a great time,
and I was driving home, you know,
and I'm driving along sunset just starting
to fucking listen to my tunes and all
of a sudden they go by this venue
and I look and what do I see?
I see Dave Chappelle and
John Mayer are doing a show.
I'm, I get the fuck Outta here. Right.
So I call up a buddy of mine that books
all the shows and I said, hey, what's,
what's the story with this?
This John Mayer, you know,
come out with his band.
Yeah.
You know this Dave, go on first is John go
on first, Blah Blah Blah. And he's like,
no. What happens is John comes out, plays
like four songs. He brings Dave out.
Dave does stand up.
Yeah.
For an hour,
an hour and a half.
And then he brings John back out
and then they just sort of riff
is Dave talks about shit. John will play
the music underneath. And I was like,
I got to fucking see that. So, uh,
me and my me and the lovely Nia,
we went down there cause I never take a
route on New Year's Eve because that is
the original Saint Patrick's Day. Um,
plus I go to the rose bowl the next day,
so I need to get my sleep before I get
absolutely hammered and pass out in the
fucking chair for a couple of
hours. Missing meatball sub. Um,
so we went down there and um,
just had such a great fucking night. And
um, I don't think I've ever seen that.
I don't think I've ever seen
two people that fucking talented
like did usually one genius and then
surrounded by a bunch of people who would
just sit in there.
Isn't he amazing?
I'm so happy to be barely playing bass
with this genius or I'm so happy to be
fucking, I dunno, whatever the fuck else.
I'm so happy to be in the ice capades
with this twirling genius. Right.
It was two of them.
And when I kind of noticed about
both of them is that they just,
it like most genius minds sake take cut.
They get rid of all the
fucking white noise.
Everything about every bit that
Chappelle did was just like,
there was no fat on it.
And he got right to the fucking point.
Another thing that I loved was,
um,
yeah,
I can't believe that I've been in this
business long enough that we're like the
older guys now.
It always blows my mind that I'm like
five years older than Dave Chappelle cause
he was already a made guy when I came in.
So I always look at him like he's
got 10 years on me, you know,
or 15. And you know, just when
I watch his act, I'm like,
this guy's clearly been doing this a
good couple of decades longer than me and
the realities, I think he's
only been doing it like six
years longer than I have.
It's something like that.
He's fucking amazing.
And what I love too is
just,
yeah,
he's that same. Um,
with all that's changed,
everybody getting offended, all of this
fucking crap. I, you get in trouble.
He hasn't changed at all.
He's just like that same guy that I saw
way back in the day when I used to go to
the Boston comedy club and watched them
go on at like two in the morning and
just start murdering at
two in the fucking morning.
And I remember I used to always sit
there going, how the fuck do you do that?
How do you get that funny at two in the
morning in front of a crowd that gave up
on the show like an hour ago and they're
tired and they just want to go home
that second he steps on
stage. Boom. He just like,
he just starts fucking killing. So, um,
you know, days update, murdering me in
the eye, like just fucking laughing,
die and having a great time and I'm,
and then he brings John Mayer back on.
I don't want to ruin the show for him
because I don't know how many they going
to do. But, uh,
basically if Dave was up there and
he would just say in like, you know,
I was watching fucking
Hawaii five o like John,
whenever you've chief fucking rifts,
it's clearly that David's just ripping,
like mayor could play whatever the fuck
he said. And Dave said that at one point,
he goes, I don't know if
you guys realize this shit,
but John Mayer can play whatever he hears.
And then he just started
doing all this crazy shit,
like make his guitar sound
like a cat or a car beeping.
Like it went beyond.
I can play songs,
like he can just do
noises around the house,
but it was fucking,
that was fucking incredible.
Um, so if you get a chance, I don't know
if you get a chance to go see the show,
definitely. Uh, definitely go do it.
Um, all right. And what that, let me,
uh, speaking of which,
let me promote this, um,
uh,
the Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit and I
forgot to fucking ask Dave Chappelle if
he ever wanted to come in and do it.
God dammit.
Um, anyways. All right. Patrice
O'Neal benefit is on February 20th,
uh, 2018. Uh,
it makes a great gift for Christmas.
This is old copy.
Uh, whatever. It's a
great fucking benefit. Uh,
we have all these amazing
comedians on it and, um,
what a great way to start the year by
seeing an all star lineup of old comedians
like myself, all the way down to new
convenience that were influenced by
Patrice O'Neal. By the way, I'm going to
post this video once a year. I got a post.
It, um, is that one when,
when Patrice was watching
the up and down game,
just his laugh and all of that shit.
I just got up once a year. I, I,
I kind of watched that
video once a year and um,
it's Kinda been nice over the years where
it became less sad for me to watch it
and now it just, uh, I don't, I get it.
I just guess I got to
the point in my grief,
which I'll never be over him not
being around, but I guess, um,
I've gotten to the point with my grief
where I just, I just think like, um,
I like what an amazing
person to have known. Um,
ah, see it's still said it's always
going to be sad, but can you dope.
It's going to be fucking
set. So I'll, I'll post that.
But those of you new to the podcast,
you know, as the years go by,
maybe even new to Patrice, which
blows my mind, but, uh, uh,
I'll post that video and then
you can go down a wonderful,
hilarious rabbit hole of anything that
fucking guy ever said. So anyways,
we're doing a benefit for his loved ones
that he was taken care of when he was,
uh,
still alive and a,
all the money after we get done paying
for the fucking venue, being upfront,
being transparent, uh, we'll go
to his loved ones. All right.
It's on February 20th in New York City.
What a Greg excuse to go to New York City.
Go skating down Rockefella center.
Watch a bunch of great comedians.
Honor the greatest comic that I ever saw.
A Patrice O'Neil.
February 20th, 2018 at the New York
City Center. All right, there we go. Um,
moving on. Uh, did anybody
watch the Celtics first?
The Houston Rockets? Holy Shit. Goddamn.
What a fucking game that was.
James Harden, by the way,
is, is fun to fucking watch.
You know I love about that guy.
He looks,
he doesn't look like a basketball player.
I look at dead guy and I go,
that guy knows how to play the trumpet.
Something about does it,
he looks like one of those fucking like
his last name should be Hargrove is some
shit. And this, I dunno, somebody
shorts his beard and his haircut.
It's very,
he looks Aba ish even though I
guess he should have a giant Afro.
I don't know what, but I taped
the game. I heard how amazing was.
So I already knew the result and I
watched the game and of course my fucking,
my uh,
my recording cut off right at the end
of the game before Al Horford hit the
shot. And, and uh, hard and kind of
had a meltdown I guess through style.
Marcus smart to the floor or some shit.
I don't know what happened
but I guess he got pissed.
He went to little Grankowski
against the bills. Um,
by the way,
congratulations to the buffalo bills.
I was actually really
pulling for you guys, um,
even though you were in our
division or whatever. Um,
I just feel like the football
gods had punished you guys enough.
It was great to see you guys back.
Get back in with tie rod. Tayla um,
so congratulations on that.
And then also can you believe the
fucking NFL season is already over?
How does that happen?
I'll tell you what else
I don't understand.
How it happens is I go to see that
unbelievable rose bowl game I just fucking
saw and I didn't even talk about the game.
All right,
here's my breakdown or the game.
Fucking
fucking, here we go. You know,
this is going to be an
intelligence breakdown in the game.
Oklahoma's going no huddled
the whole fucking first half.
Georgia's Goddamn head is spinning around.
They don't know what to
do right before they have,
they kicked an onside kick, which I
get this six second slap you thinking,
all right, I don't want this
guy to run this ball back.
We'll kick it to an up person.
They'll, we'll fucking tackle
them, Yada, Yada, Yada,
and that'll be over.
Who the fuck knew Georgia was going to
come out through a quick fucking pass,
get in field goal range and instead
of being down by three scores,
17 points.
They're only down by two scores were
like dumb fucking move and George is
getting the Goddamn ball.
All right. No, no, I'm sorry.
Oklahoma got the ball. They kicked
off to them. That was the thing.
They were up by 17 fucking points and
they would get the ball after the half.
I mean they had their foot on their
fucking neck. I get the onside thing.
I don't fault him for that, but in the
third quarter when they stopped going,
no huddle,
they started playing Marty ball and
they're trying to bleed out the fucking,
I actually get that fucking move.
But then Georgia scores a touchdown.
Now they've scored 10 on answered.
You're still trying to bleed the clock.
They score another touchdown.
Now they've gone 17 on answered.
You still in your huddle,
they score 24 fucking unanswered points
to go up by seven before you finally
decide out of the fucking blue to go back
to no huddle.
And the second they go back to no huddle,
Georgia has a problem again. Bam.
They score a fucking touchdown.
I'm running out of sound effects
cause Allie, they fumble the ball.
Your return it.
Now you're up by fucking seven.
You've got to give it to Georgia bulldogs.
They have Georgia Goddamn fucking
bulldogs. Hey, they came back, tied it up,
and for the first time ever in a hundred,
and I don't know how many goddamn years
are the fucking Rosebowl. All right.
They had an overtime game and
it doesn't just go to one.
Over time it goes to
two, two overtimes. Um,
congratulations to the Georgia bulldogs,
um,
on an amazing victory. Uh, I don't
know why I was, I was actually,
even though I'm a big SCC guy,
I was kind of torn.
I was a little emotionally torn.
I was rooting for Oklahoma
for whatever fucking reason.
I just decided I was
going to root for them.
I don't have anything
against Georgia, but, um,
I was,
uh,
I was actually also on another level kind
of sight to see Georgia wind because j
law had,
is so fucking pissed that
Ohio state didn't get in and
he thinks CSCC is totally
fucking overrated.
MMM.
And you know,
he was arguing for the PAC 12 he was
at one point he was fucking arguing.
I was like, Jesus Christ
Jay, it's eight o'clock,
you're already fucking wine and a
by the buck guides. And he said,
the most innocent voice every pointed at
somebody else at the tailgate. He goes,
he brought it up, he put it, he went
from like going and where we fucking,
we beat Penn state and they'll
say, he's goes, he brought it up.
So I thought it was kind of funny,
you know, and then Alabama also once,
so both SCC teams,
SCC teams that got in are now
going to play for the championship.
So the SEC is going to
win another fucking title.
And it just cracks me up that that's
going to bump j law head and he just will
not admit that on the Ohio state buckeyes
had no fucking business last year of
being one of the final four,
considering they lost to Penn state.
And then Penn state won
the title. He goes, Bill,
you're not listening to what I'm saying.
I'm saying that Penn State got screwed.
But that's all he'll say.
He will not say that Ohio state did not
deserve to be in their last year despite
the fact that they then went there and
lost 24, seven and he's all, I'll fucking,
Deshaun Watson was unbelievable. It's
like, dude, he wasn't tackling guys too.
You scored no points.
So I feel like Ohio state
this year got punished.
Um, for the fucking snooze fest. They
basically ate their balls last year.
A wanted to get another Saturday night,
eight o'clock spot at the club.
They're like, no buddy, you're
going to get a Wednesday. Um,
and I actually think that Ohio state
would have done great, you know,
considering when I watched their game,
how their front for are all first and
second round draft picks on the defensive
side. Um, I actually agree with j law had,
but like you don't get
your cake and eat it.
You don't get to suck and get in and lose
by 24 points and don't even score one
fucking point the year before.
And then the next year when you're
actually good enough to get an also get
rewarded, you know? So that's my
beef, that's my beef with j law here,
but I still love the Getty death,
so we'll get over it. Um, anyways,
amazing fucking game. And um, we,
we went the whole game without having
an incident until the very end.
I Dunno what happened.
Bart. Nick was, you know,
a little boost up and I think he bumped
into somebody in front of us in this
fucking guy who I swear
to God was as old as me.
It starts yelling at
Barton Creek and Barton.
Nick is just staring at him and I'm
just staring at him and he's like,
I'll be a nice stop bumping you.
We just fucking stare at him and
I'm looking at this guy like, dude,
you're as old as me and you're yelling
at the human version of a fucking Kodiak
bear.
And the guy didn't know what she was
waiting for us to respond and we didn't
respond,
but it was just lie had,
we were all just staring at the guy and
they just looked at Joe and he goes,
fuck you. They fucking turns
around. It's like, dude,
between all of us were
about 225 years old.
This is the first Rosebowl ever that
is going into fucking over time.
You want, you want to get kicked out, uh,
you want to roll around in these
stadium floors with you fucking,
this guy wasn't even
wearing true religion jeans,
which puppet for Come Dad James in
the last fucking 12 years. He's, he,
I think he was, he was
probably wearing the, you know,
the Lee jeans and on the tag it just
said in giant bold letters, Lee,
you know, which where I came from
basically meant that, you know,
your family was barely,
could barely afford to live in,
in a blue collar town. Um,
if he had the lead genes,
the lead genes in the gap jeans,
you know.
Yeah. They have Levi. Yeah. I believe
that's how simple life was back then.
If you had Levi, that meant that your
parents were actually doing well.
Okay. And it before, uh, diesel
jeans came in and fucked it.
Just fucked it all up.
You know,
jeans were like 25,
30 bucks and I know with inflation will
just say jeans for like 50 bucks. Right?
Then all of a sudden diesel comes along
and then like twice that and the next
thing you know,
that's like $200 pairs of jeans
that suffocate your balls and still
can't get up and over your flat ass.
I don't fucking understand what,
I don't understand genes.
And then that tapered in down the bottom.
Like you're going to do ballet and
people need to see your feet, right?
Like you're going to
reenact the thriller video.
Um, I dunno. Anyways,
let's read some of the fucking,
the letters here over the a that I got.
If I can find them. Oh, I guess I
didn't copy and paste them. Did I?
Where are they? All right, here we go.
This is a very dramatic email.
It says it's the name of
this email is good. Bye,
dear bill.
I am sadly no longer a fan.
It's really too bad because I was a huge
fit. All right. What do you think I did?
What did I say? Who
did I say it about? Uh,
went to see you and Paul Versey in Albany,
New York. Oh, that was a great show.
And I've watched every one of your
specials as well as F is for family.
And I'm an avid podcast listener.
All right. So what he's doing now,
he or she is doing is establishing that
they listened to every fucking thing
that I do. This is what everybody
does when they complain.
You can't just complain.
You have to establish credibility.
Like when people argue politics,
you know,
they sit there and they
go, Hey, I'm a democrat.
I'm for gay marriage,
upper legalizing pot.
But this Obama has gone too far
or the other way around. You know,
I'm fucking Blah, blah blah.
But this Trump, this is what
everybody does. All right?
He goes, I'm not super
religious. Oh, Gj age.
You're not super religious. But I
obviously said something about your God.
All right,
but you took it too far when you trash
Jesus at anyone who believes in them.
When the fuck did I do that through?
Do you understand that this is unscripted?
I don't remember half the
Shit I said today. I mean,
if you want to take it
seriously, by all means, he goes,
you take your shots here and there,
which is tolerable. But in the 1228,
17 replayed portion of the podcast,
uh,
it was just too much. Oh,
I gotta listen to that one.
I didn't hear it the first time and I
wish whomever is picking the replays had
more of an inkling than to
play that expert expert.
As much as I wish you didn't say it.
Um,
well aren't you glad that they played it?
So now you can know how bad a person I am.
A,
this probably won't matter to you
because at this point you don't need me
anymore.
Oh,
come on.
The end of the comedy hut.
That being said, I bet
big promoter and a
supporter for a long time.
This has to be a woman.
This they're just doing,
they're just going 100% guilt.
I'm sure you will never read this as you
probably have a screener at this point.
Uh, just taking a shot. I do
wish you continued success.
I'll look at this and they're
still going to go out as a class.
This person's a class act and nothing
but the best for you and the lovely Mia.
It's Nia with an end.
You know what? I'm a,
I'm saying goodbye to you the amount of
times that I said Nia on the podcast and
you still don't even know my wife's
name and you have the nerve to get upset
with me cause I trashed
the old Jay star there.
Why don't you,
what would Jesus do?
Jesus would forgive me and continue
to listen to the podcast, wouldn't he?
I would think. Um, anyways,
uh, that being said,
or being a bump up of, uh, uh,
for the lovely mia and
your daughter in there, uh,
Boston sucks and go fuck yourself.
Um,
ps checkout, Gary Newman's new
album, all synth, but really cool.
Alright, pss, if you don't read
this or if you do read this,
don't use a southern accent because
I'm from New York. Lol. You know what?
You're going to be back. I gotta
fill in. You're going to be back.
Um,
I love these fucking people that it's
just like all the dumb shit that I say.
I've trashed people that smoke weed.
I trash women.
I trust Jesus. I trash fucking
anybody who's a Republican.
Anybody who's a Democrat, all of this
fucking shit. And everybody listens.
And listens and listens, then
all of a sudden, once you know,
fucking comes into your world like I the
trash above ground pools and all of a
sudden I got to listen to somebody going,
hi.
You know,
just because I can't afford to
take a goddamn hole in my backyard.
You know,
look at that right there.
Offensive to southern people is if there's
people up north that can't afford to
fucking have a backhoe come in there and
whatever the fuck it is that they do,
right, dig into the Goddamn ground. Um,
hey. You know what I mean? All right.
See you draw the line of Jesus. Well,
there you go.
I mean,
as far as my limited understanding of
Jesus and what exactly it was he was
trying to prove with all this party
tricks with the fish and the bread over
there. Um, I think he was a
very forgiving person, sir.
So I think if you're truly into the
teachings of Jesus and you're truly strong
enough spiritually,
you can handle one 20 minute fucking
clip from a Goddamn podcasts from a few
fucking years ago. You know what the real
thing is here, sir, is you need to up,
okay?
What I'm saying is not going to infiltrate
into your fucking soul and all of a
sudden make you possess and
have you kill your whole family.
Why can't you just look
at me and feel fit?
Sad for me that I'm going to go to hell
and that you're going to go to heaven.
You're going to be on a
little puffy cloud. There is.
I'm burning forever, right?
Why don't you just look at it that way,
all right?
It's not that he's leaving. It's that
you know all the dumb shit that I say,
all of the dumb shit that I fucking say,
and then that one thing you
look past everything else,
all right? But whatever, you know
it'd be more pouchy. God bless you.
God bless you in your search.
I wish you well on your search to
a Jesus only positivity podcast.
All right? All right.
Your journey to Aa. Bear,
dare Billy to Shift Drinking Albino
ginge dad bod once a solid c cup now as
solid eight cups or moves a
lot and a mouthful. All right,
me and another friend of bill w agree
that you're qualifying story for AA is
unfolding perfectly. All
right, here we go. Um,
I'm an alcoholic,
so you must be an alcoholic.
All right, I'm going to lose this guy's
offense. I hate fucking Aa people.
There's nothing more self involved than
someone who has an addictive personality
and all they think is whatever happened
to them, whatever they're going through,
you also have to be going through because
they are the center of the fucking
universe. All right, from your
off the wagon on the wagon,
off the wagon to your,
let's try some controlled drinking.
You are perfect. A material, uh,
can't wait to hear about your surrender
and your acknowledgement that you lack
and that lack of power is your
dilemma. No, Jesus Christ.
Stop projecting all of your shit.
You fucking loser.
I fucking hate people in Aa. I really do.
Not all of them, but people like this.
Listen Dude,
just because you are under the sink,
turn your kid's birthday drinking fucking
mouthwash. Don't break my balls over.
I don't have to go to your
dumb ass fucking meeting.
I've gone to some AA meetings.
Do the stories you guys tell
my GI is on the fucking ground.
You guys make me look
like a fucking fairy. Uh,
he's in denial right now.
The gag of gagging by dude,
I'm gonna tell you
something that I just did.
I just went off the wagon for six days,
drank like an animal yesterday
in while I was drunk,
effortlessly said, you know, and I'm
not drinking anymore effortlessly.
I didn't have to surrender and say,
I have no power over this.
Bad,
bad.
I don't need to go down to your dumb ass
group and smoked cigarettes and eating
donuts with all you guys down there
with the a blown out fucking wallflower
noses. All right, I'm fine. Anyways.
And your discovery that there is
a power greater than yourself.
One Who can solve all your problems.
Yeah.
Or one that you can dump all your shit
on. It's a great life. You could even say,
even say it's a life second to none.
One day at a time. Easy. Does
it keep it simple, stupid.
I just can't wait to hear you speak
from the podium delivering a message of
hope.
It's not the meetings you make.
It's the steps you take. Thankfully
there are only 12 of them. Ah,
love your biggest 32 year
old blonde Nigerian fan.
Um, Hey, God bless you in your
sobriety. But no, all right, whatever.
Um,
uh,
this is how my sobriety works. I just like
how I feel when I'm sober from a tall,
I like how I look.
I like the weight that I become.
It's total vanity and there becomes
a point in your life where you just,
you just too fucking old to drink.
It just beats the shit out of you.
So, uh, thank you sir.
But I don't need to go down
there and surrender and you know,
I'm telling you right now,
if you think you're a fucking alcoholic,
go to a Goddamn AA meeting. These
fucking people, I swear to God,
they'll tell stories where like,
like they're sitting there,
half their nose is hanging off
their face and that just go in like,
so I take some duct tape and I fucking
tape my nose back onto my face.
And all I'm thinking is I got to go back
to the liquor store and get more booze.
Man.
When I got arrested for drinking and
driving about 30 fucking years ago,
um, I remember why I was required to
go to two AA meetings and I was like,
these people are out of their fucking,
and every story was that they would do.
And then I belted my wife in the face.
I actually hit my wife over
the head with our own child.
And the crazy thing is, is I would
say, can like, you know what,
I got to go get a drink
and they'll look,
I shouldn't be laughing at people that
have that much of a fucking problem. Okay.
But, um, I could tell you this, sir,
I don't need to surrender to anything.
All right.
I know that I,
there are times in my life when I drink
too much and I have the ability to look
at myself, say I have a problem
and then fucking walk away from it.
MMM. That's it. All right.
And I want to tell you,
y'all want you to answer me.
Name one of your fucking Aa friends down
there that can come off the wagon and
drank like I did.
You know the yesterday I
drank six out of seven days.
I had two drinks one day I had a beer
the next day, then drink the next day,
had two drinks at the John
Mayer Chappelle thing,
and then had two drinks the next day
and then fucking got hammered at at the
Rose Bowl. And now I can just be like, all
right, fuck that. I'm not doing that now.
That's it. I can, I can do that, sir.
I'm sorry that you can't do that.
I'm sorry that you need to go down
there and put your arms around a budget.
Well,
all go down together.
They gotta give you a little chip.
Every little your little fucking cookie,
you know. God bless you. I mean fucking
people might lose it on this podcast.
God bless you buddy.
If that's what the fuck you have to do.
MMM.
Are you one of those alcoholics too
who still a fucking cunt, you know,
and then blames everything on your
fucking disease. Oh, sorry bro,
I just got to let us shit coming up.
You know,
you've got that built in fucking excuse.
MMM.
Anyways,
not saying they're all like that.
Cause I know a lot of cool people
that are in fucking Aa, but like, um,
I really think that if you're,
if you're an alcoholic,
that when you're drinking your life
just like falls apart. It really does.
You know what I mean?
MMM.
I mean I wake up,
hung over for flights and it sucks.
And I definitely am not a casual drinker.
I'm definitely a fucking binge drinker
and I know that I shouldn't be doing that
shit.
But if I actually had a real fucking job,
that's my biggest problem is
I don't have a fucking job.
Okay.
So like I have to tell you like when,
okay.
You know, when I'm like really
fucking busy and I have shit to do,
I don't really drink. But the thing that
like right now it's fucking Tuesday,
it's nine in the morning.
I'm sitting here in my fucking pajamas
and I could just sit here for the rest of
the, for the rest of the Goddamn week.
I don't have anything to do. I mean,
if I wasn't so fucking responsible,
patting myself on the back,
I mean there's a bunch of shit that I
could just put off to next week and,
and I could just sit here
drinking non fucking stop.
So that's the problem.
My problem is my fucking free time.
So, um, I'm gonna I, I respect the
fact that you're trying to help me.
Um, my wife, my wife on the hand, uh,
I've told her a bunch of times saying, I
am I an alcoholic. She goes, God, Bill,
you're not an alcoholic.
You're not a fucking alcoholic.
So I would think that she would know she
lives with me, but I appreciate it. Um,
and all these going to say the whole time
as he's in denial Elo, the Loyola bug.
And Excel. You know what alcoholics,
you'd like the like Madonna,
Madonna always just did over the top
shocking stuff, you know what I mean?
And then if you'd been like Madonna,
that music videos sucked and
then they get to hide behind.
Well all I was looking for was the
reaction. It's art. Art is just, you know,
you can't judge it and blah
blah. No, that fucking steaks.
Yeah.
So there you go. Um, I don't know.
Listen, I'm open to the idea.
If I am an alcoholic,
but there's no fucking way I'll
ever be able to go to a meeting.
There's no way I'm not going to go down
there and just not fucking laugh my
balls off. Listening to your, your,
your fucking stories that would make
Keith Richards go. Jesus Christ.
Um,
okay.
I know a guy that fucking, he
drank so much. He did a face plant,
his fucking teeth.
One of his teeth bucket
went through his lower lip.
All right.
Any woke up the next day with his fucking
lips looking like a goddamn duck bill.
Any, any Jew immediately
grabbed the fucking, you know,
a 40 ouncer it put a straw in it so
he could keep drinking as the alcohol.
Most of it was going in his mouth.
Part of it was going through
the hole that was in his face.
Yeah.
As much as my moral is, I am, I'd
be like, all right, you know what,
I'm going to take a fucking year off
at this point. You know, so whatever.
I sir,
I actually,
I think that there's different
degrees of abusing alcohol.
I definitely abuse it.
Admittedly,
I'm wrong and it's definitely gotten
not a control, but I'm like a habit guy.
Like if I'm working out,
I'm fucking working out like a maniac.
If I'm sitting around
and I'm eating bad food,
I eat bad food like a fucking maniac,
but not to the point of like
someone that has addiction.
Like I, I'll lead bad to the
point I put on 1520 pounds.
I don't have to be cut out of my house.
I don't balloon up a hundred fucking
pounds the way somebody who's addicted to
food would.
All right.
And I'll go out and I'll go
on a fucking booze binge.
It'd be like, I got to knock this
off. What the fuck am I doing?
I got to knock this off and I'm
just kind of able to do it. And
uh, I feel like I have to apologize to
you that I'm able to do that. I'm sorry.
I look like I'm done right now.
I will have no problem going.
I Dunno.
As long as I fucking want to go,
you know,
it's not like I'm never going to have a
glass of wine with a great fucking meal
again. But, um, I dunno, whatever.
I appreciate your, uh, your concern. But,
um,
I am going to be sober now just out of
vanity because I got this new fucking
diet right.
And the Dean del Ray was telling me about.
And when I do that,
when I,
when I'm on his diet and if I just go
for a fucking walk around the block with
my lovely daughter,
I do that a couple times a day and I'm
not drinking and I'm not eating sugar or
anything like that. I barely
have to work out and, uh, and I,
the fucking,
the everything just falls off you.
Um, and it's the easiest way to stay in
shape and I fucking hate working out.
So,
um,
that's way more appealing to me then.
Um,
you know, as much fun as, as I had
over the last fucking week. I mean,
it's way more appealing at my age,
you know, and plus I got a kid,
you know, I've got to have
a kid and I can't be like,
fucking, I just can't do it.
I just can't do it. I can't have it
in my fucking life and that's it.
So I don't need to go down there and do
all of that bullshit. All right. I'm,
I'm a comedian. All right. I
don't like groups. All right,
lady. Who's bad at
arguing? Uh, dear Billy.
Backward balls backwards. False.
Uh, I'm actually a 15 year old girl.
Oh,
Jay z.
The fuck who the f Andrew, you'd
try to get me in trouble here. Uh,
so I guess you couldn't say really
say that. I'm a lady. Oh my God,
this is already creeping me out yet. But
I love your podcast and listen to a 24,
seven because I feel like balanced needs,
oh,
balance needs to be restored to the world.
After all the females listening to
Dr Phil and loose women have gotten a
slightly fucked up view on things.
Um,
I respect that you're not going to let
mainstream media have the only say on the
truth. In other words, what you're
saying is you like to hear my opinion.
I'm not always right, but you'll listen
to it. I appreciate that. All right.
[inaudible] my whole life,
the 15 years of my life,
Jesus Christ,
that this shit in my house said for 15
years I've been meaning to get to it. Um,
your whole life is 15 years.
That's incredible. Uh,
my whole life I've been bad at arguing
either I say the wrong thing at the wrong
time or I focus on the wrong point or
I'm easily manipulated by guilt trips,
et cetera. Uh, whatever it is,
I can never get it right or
stand my ground. For example,
I have this one friend
who is literally three.
I was the literal,
a literal three year old on the inside.
I thought you said you were hanging
out with a three year old. I was like,
this is getting even more creepy.
Um,
I can't say shit to
her without her crying.
One time she wanted some of my food,
but I told her that I hadn't had
breakfast and couldn't share that day.
She said to me, you're [inaudible], you're
so mean. What the fuck is your problem?
What? Yeah, you got, you get
that person out of your life.
I just gave her some food cause I hate
it when people think bad about me.
But inside I was like, bitch, what?
It took me like two hours to realize
that she didn't even think I was mean.
She just wanted the food and she knew
how to get it. Oh my God. You know,
something.
Your thought process that it took me
till I was 37 to realize that you're way
ahead of the curve here.
What's your realizing for the first time
in your life is that this people out
there that are not good people.
See. So what I did was I, I,
I went out into the world where you are
as a 15 year old and existed as that
person til about 37 before I actually
started to examine human behavior.
And,
um,
yeah,
so what,
where you are right now is when you
first start to realize that there's these
constant life.
Um,
what's going to happen is
like two or three days later,
or an hour later after the moment,
you're going to be like,
oh fuck yeah. She said Blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
And that cause she meant that it's
cause she, she wanted x, y, and Z. Well,
the more you do that,
the more you're going to be able to be
in the moment and you're going to catch
people in the moment. And then once
you're able to do it in real time,
people aren't going to be able to
fuck with you anymore. And then when,
and then the only thing you'll have
to learn how to do is the judgment.
Is this worth me?
You know,
applying this skill in real time.
Like yesterday,
that guy who turned around and yelled,
fuck you at Bart, nick and all that.
There was like four of us
wanting him overtime. Rosebowl
not even worth engaging.
We all just stared at him
and then he didn't know what
to do. He yelled, fuck you.
And then he turned around and he felt
good. He said, fuck you to four guys.
We didn't do anything. He feels good
in secure around his wife, you know,
and nobody got kicked out.
Nobody had to fight or whatever.
And then there's other times when
you actually say something back,
somebody who's, I'll read the rest of
this, but um, right out of the gate,
you're being too hard on yourself,
right?
Most of the girls in my class are pretty
weak physically and it happens to be
that as a girl,
I have unnaturally broad shoulders,
excuse the pun,
a and weigh about two pounds
more than most of them.
The fact is hard to ignore when you're
staring at their can faces while the
giggle behind their hands.
I have violent tendencies,
which I'm working on,
but I know I can beat the shit out of
them and that makes it so much harder to
verbal,
verbally argue.
Uh,
they're much better at it than me.
So even when I'm right,
I lose and I always end up
wanting to just uppercut,
send an upper cut straight
to their fucking skull.
MMM.
Whatever.
All right.
I would love a few pointers as to what
to do in an argument and how to tell them
when I'm being manipulated before I start
latching onto the fucked up mind game.
MMM.
Of doing things. Some advice
would be great. Thanks a lot
and go fuck yourself. Ps,
me and my sister have a huge disagreement
agreement because it's my personal
opinion that guys,
whoever,
girlfriend should still be able to go
to strip clubs and have a good time
without their girlfriend getting mad.
My sister says that for me to say that
I must have no respect for myself and
we'll end up with a piece of shit guy.
Jesus.
Those are two extreme
opinions and my right,
or do I have some sort of self respect
issues that I'm not aware of yet?
All right,
let me comment on the first fucking thing.
All right?
Kids are mean. Kids bullied,
they gang up on you.
You never should resort to
physical violence, all right?
But what she gotta do is you
got to fight fire with fire.
So what you have to do, all
right, is nobody's perfect.
So you have to find that fucking thing,
all right?
You have to find that fucking thing,
And you just get them with that,
all right?
And then they,
they know will hurt their feelings,
especially if they're good
looking popular people.
You can really fucking get
to them all right? Like,
here's something that I do that
I learned to do after years
of arguing with people after my shows.
You know,
if somebody came up to me and
was like, Hey, let me tell you,
sent it that stuff he said about where
and you're gonna fucking get Gaga.
And as they yelled, all of that, I used to
try to argue my points going, well, hey,
you know,
it's just jokes.
I also made fun of people
in that hurricane. You
didn't get offended by that.
You know what I learned to
dope when someone was given,
when they were giving me
shit, I would just go, hey,
you got something between your teeth.
That's what I would say.
Even though they didn't. And then
they would be so fucking mortified,
they walk away and then they'd
be gone. Like you know, you know,
sucking on their teeth and shit and
she should just shut them the fuck up.
So you need to find your version of that.
Okay?
So what I would do is I would
really study them. All right?
And what you gotta do is you just got to
find something that's wrong with them.
Maybe their ear lobes are too big. And I
know this is very immature and this is,
this is super fucking mean. And that is
an adult. I shouldn't tell you to do this.
Cause adults go with those people.
They're not your real friends.
You don't need to stoop to their level
and they give you all this fucking air
quote, mature advice, but you know what?
That doesn't help you when you go
back into the shit the next day.
Tell a teacher, none of that
Shit fucking works. All right?
Because those fucking evil
fucking consequate terrible
parents are going to find
the time they're going to find you.
So that's what I would do.
All right? There's no way. One of them
doesn't have a slightly crooked nose.
There's no way one of them's titty.
Is it a little bit bigger than the other?
Or maybe they had nipples point down this
something fucked up about their chin.
If you know you got to
fight fire with fire,
if they're talking about you fucking
shoulders, all right? First of all,
laugh at it. Learned to laugh at
yourself. All right, let's look at me.
I'm an old freckled ball,
redheaded count, okay?
In all of those things should really
end any dream that I ever had in life.
But if you just roll with it,
if you steer into it,
and if I just be an old bald,
redheaded con then,
then w w what can you do to me?
Okay.
You just, you got to get comfy. So I
would get more comfortable with yourself.
All right? And uh, I'm sure your
shoulders are fine and all of that stuff.
And when they make fun of your shoulders,
laugh, and then I would say, yeah,
my shoulders are as fucked up as your
crooked Teddy's or just you somehow you
laugh at your shit and then you fucking,
you get them.
It get them. Just tell them you
just go. Do you once, you know,
just tell them they got bad
breath. You got any, some I
don't. You'll find, I wish,
you know what you could have if he just
could have sent me a picture of him,
I would have helped you out.
But then I would've gotten in trouble
because you're teaching them to bully
Bababababa. You know, all
of these people who want to,
who want to fix problems with five minutes
on fucking doctor Phil, by the way,
did I call it?
You see that big scandal over there
now granted and is sitting until proven
guilty.
All doctor Phil fucking bringing
the guests up a notch there.
All right, I punched a girl.
Woe is another one. Hey Bill,
like your input on a
situation. Uh, I was recently,
I was recently at a concert,
some drunk skank accused me of
stealing her friend's phone.
Uh, I told her you got the
wrong guy, her and her fuck her.
And her father friend tried to wrestle
my phone away from me and I pushed them
off.
Then she sucker punched me in the eye,
big bruise bloody I and our friend
snatched my phone out of my pocket due to
work there.
Came up and I told them what happened.
He didn't seem to believe and was
clearly buddy buddy with the girls.
So they go off and we're giggling around,
giggling around. I don't want that. That
means after a few minutes I go up to a,
to a Fatso.
Oh,
I go up to Fatso and tell
her to give me my phone back.
She realized it was
mine in handed it over.
As I went to walk away,
scag number one in a Douche bag,
boyfriend accosted me
again and grabbed me.
I punched both of them in the face
and then security escorted me out.
I think I was justified to
hit her in this case. What?
Say you then go fuck yourself.
Uh, yeah, I see. I see.
I don't have a problem with any
of that. I don't, no problem.
Someone gets physical with you, you
know, you take one punch to the eye,
you're all your physically fucked up.
You didn't do anything wrong.
Some point you got to defend
yourself. All right. God bless you.
I think he showed remarkable
restraint to only hit them both once.
That was an easy one. I wouldn't even,
I wouldn't even concerned about it.
Not at all. And in fact, you probably made
both of them better people. Hopefully.
Probably not. But you know, if I will, you
know, when you get punched in the face,
you know,
if you're an adult,
at some point you gotta be looking
at yourself going like, all right,
did I do something there? If you
didn't, then you're like, all right,
this person's an asshole and I needed to
have them out of my life. But you know,
if you did,
you got to be that guy and that was kind
of shooting my mouth off there. Right?
That's what I would do. Um, all right,
got two girls pregnant help.
Uh, dude, I can't help you.
Um, there's no help for
this. Uh, I buckled down for
the next fucking 18 years.
All right.
Hello Bill.
I have a big problem and I'm hoping
that you and the lovely Nia can help out
with it.
All right,
let me start by saying that I don't live
in a trailer is something I'm a normal
26 year old guy.
I was dating this girl and we broke up
a couple months ago when we broke up.
A couple of weeks later,
I met this little Hottie,
I started hooking up with her and then
I got a call a couple of weeks ago.
My Ex is three months pregnant
with my child and she's keeping it.
I then broke things off with
the hottie. Well, guess what?
I knocked her up to buddy. Ah,
did you ever take a health class?
Do you know how to fucking
to help people get pregnant?
Neither one knows the other is
pregnant and I have no idea what to do.
I broke things off with the Hottie to
work on being there from my ex and the
kid.
I want to be there for her and help
her out with all the prenatal stuff.
It'd be a great dad. Now it seems
my life is not going to be that way.
The other girl wants to have the baby too.
I use protection with this girl,
but not enough, I guess.
What does that mean, dude?
If you use a condom, I would get
a maternity. Uh, first of all,
I would make both of them subject to it.
Okay.
Because you broke up for
a couple of months, right?
Get a maternity test times to do not
give either one of them a fucking dime or
else, you know, in some states, the second
you start paying, that kid is yours.
That's the first thing
I would do personally,
I would do it was tell
both of them you situation.
The second thing I would get more,
make more both of them get a fuck.
Is it a maternity tests? A paternity
test. I said maternity, paternity test.
They go, oh, Jesus. Um,
the other girl wants the other
baby to blah, blah, blah.
Uh,
my ex was on birth control
yet I still knocked her up.
If I had to be with one of them, it would
be the new girl because she is hotter.
I'm a pig,
sue me.
And we also like a lot of the same things.
What should I do?
I'm so sick in an exhausted
of worrying about this.
I just want to do the right things.
Thank you. And Go fuck yourself. Well,
I would tell both of them what's going on.
I would get a paternity test,
not a maternity tests.
Get a paternity test and make
sure those are your kids.
And I would, if you want to be with
the Hottie, be with the hottie.
There you go. And then I would
stay in the life of the other one.
That's what I would do.
And I would s fucking get a vasectomy
or cut up a garden hose because whatever
the fuck you're using is not working.
I'm all right. That's the podcast.
Oh, it's a long, one hour and 20 minutes
here. Happy new year to everybody.
Uh, good luck to Ya. Um,
I apologize to anybody in Aa
or whatever the fuck it is.
Um, and that's it. I'm sipping
my tea, going to go eat healthy.
All right. And I will go back to booze
at some point if I fucking want to,
cause I don't think I have a
problem. All right, that's it. Uh,
I'll check in on you on Thursday.